si vous demandez un russe ce que sotchi
lui inspire il vous répondra sans
tromper mais aussi stand
en deux décennies la petite station
balnéaire soviétique est devenue
l'eldorado des russes fortunés
les statues de staline ont été
déboulonnées les lénine est encore sur
la vie
un grand écart que les habitants de
sotchi assume avec humour laurine
autrefois si tranquille ressemble à un
grand chantier il regarde passer le vent
la métamorphose 106 décès tour d'hier
[Musique]
s'il en a une qui ne travaille pas c'est
la mer noire si calme si chaude toujours
la même
le week-end à sotchi ils viennent à elle
ou son échappe c'est souvent
[Musique]
sacha le plombier préfère se retirer
loin des foules pour vivre ça sotchi
éternelle nina boch dans la mer noire
avec gourmandise guide infatigable de
cette ville qu'elle affectionne
par-dessus tout et puis il y à bastien
il vient de rejoindre son père marcial
ils sont aujourd'hui les deux seuls
français de sotchi a tiré par le sel des
affaires ils en sont tombés amoureux eux
aussi ils disent tous que pour rien au
monde il ne vivrait d'ailleurs sans ce
cocktail étonnant et détonnant d'énergie
et de nostalgie
[Musique]
oui je la tête qui tourne
la semaine bastien travail dans le salon
de thé qui vient d'ouvrir le samedi ils
retrouvent les bords de mer c'est là
qu'il nous a donné rendez vous pour une
verrine yacht à 100 euros de l'heure
c'est une des activités favorites des
moscovites en week end
la meilleure période ici c'est la fin de
l'été quand le soleil est au max la
ville se remplie de monde il ya un
esprit de fête je viens ici tous les ans
il ya la mer et beaucoup d'hommes beau
et bronzé
c'est une chance énorme de vivre ici
c'est le meilleur endroit toute la
russie chez mieux qu'à moscou
en pleine saison estivale ce qui
ressemble à n'importe quel port de
plaisance pour riches et célèbres les
filles jeunes et doré se donne des airs
de starlettes
bastien niçois d'origine ne se sent pas
dépensez pas du tout la monumentale
tesla mentalité du caucase du sud de la
russie si on peut comparer ça au nord de
la france sur la france
sotchi n'a pas toujours été aussi
branché au début du siècle il n'y avait
qu'un village et 150 km de plage
quand elle se promène en bord de mer
avec ses amis rituel immuable du
vendredi soir li na se rappelle du temps
où sotchi est devenue la station
balnéaire du caucase dans les années 60
malgré un talent immense de notre pays
c'est ici et uniquement ici que tout le
monde venait pour se reposer les
vacanciers venaient du nord et de
l'extrême orient il faut que vous
sachiez que pour un russe qui vit dans
ces régions froides les vacances c'est
avant tout pouvoir passer quelques jours
à la mer est pour beaucoup issus c'était
le paradis
nina est d'abord venu à sotchi pour y
travailler elle était interprète franco
russe car à l'époque soviétique la ville
accueillait de nombreux touristes
étrangers sotchi c'était la vitrine de
l'urss depuis nina n'a jamais quitté les
rives de la mer noire mais d'ailleurs
pourquoi ce nom la mer noire la légende
dit que les marins qui s'arrêtait ici
remonter leur encre et les découvre est
complètement oxydé et noirci il ne
savait pas que la mer contenait de
l'hydrogène sulfuré alors ils ont
baptisé la mer noire la mer dans l'eau
était connu pour noircir tous les métaux
l'eau est à 28 degrés c'est à la nuit
tombée que nina aiment s'y baigner quand
elle est un peu plus fraîche et plus
sombre encore ce n'est pas une mer
hostile bien au contraire c'est une mer
chaude agréable et généreuse car elle
fait du bien une mère qui ou ses bras à
tous et qui semble nous parler nous dire
bagne toi profite de mon nom c'est une
mère accueillante il n'y a pas de
meilleur mot pour la définir
des propos que les touristes ne
démentiront pas 10 millions ils viennent
chaque été le vendredi soir il déambule
gentiment tout semble paisible le week
end ne fait que commencer
[Musique]
samedi matin sacha le plombier prend le
large vers les montagnes au volant de sa
jeep militaire des années 70
[Musique]
il a acheté pour quelques centaines
d'euros un ancien général
c'était un rêve depuis tout petit je
vais acheter et depuis mon âme d'enfant
a été satisfaite
on aimerait sortir le week-end pour
partir la montagne
il y aura
passé le week end avec un homme du
peuple et vous comprendrez l'âme russe
vous avait-il dit
alors nous sommes partis à la pêche à la
truite avec sa femme et son petit fils
à l'époque de l'union soviétique
tout le monde avait droit des séjours
ici
on payait 10% du prix et tout le reste
était prise en charge par les usines
du coup les gens venaient pour se
soigner ou tout simplement se reposer
mon père est venu la toute première fois
parce qu'il était malade il s'est
longtemps soigné dans les centres de
cure de la région et du coup toute la
famille est restée
venir à sotchi c'était prendre soin de
sa santé de soi et cette tradition est
restée et pour cela rien de meilleur que
de banias un bain de vapeur à la russe
l'homme aux ballets sept gardiens des
lieux il n'a pas l'air comme ça mais il
est là pour fêter
hive khalip moga ce sont des branches
des eucalyptus qui dégage des huiles
très très bonne pour la peau
on peut aussi faire ça avec des feuilles
de chêne et ça c'est du boulot notre
arbre russes traditionnelles
et puis pour un traitement énergétique
on mélange le chêne le boulot et
l'eucalyptus c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux
pour la santé
les feuilles sont plongés dans l'eau
bouillante est certes ensuite à cingler
le corps pour favoriser la circulation
du sang dans la pièce il fait 100 degrés
et finalement on apprend que foot et
c'est aimer
ce à travers mes branchages je donne
tout
de la santé de l'amour
rien d'autre
les sensations sont bonnes on a
l'impression de s'évaporer complètement
et de remettre à nouveau ses
doudous et rugueux à la fois
on se débarrasse de toutes les mauvaises
énergie qu'on a emmagasinée
qu'est ce que ça fait du bien c'est bon
tu peux te relever c'est fini vous venez
souvent ici sachant un bon russe doit se
purifier une fois par semaine
et après les coups de fouet un bon bain
glacé l'hiver sacha et olga se roule
dans la neige fraîche il ne manquerait
pas un peu de douceur dans tout ça
pierre legrand disait qu'avec l'énergie
d'un bon banian on pouvait voler dans
les airs mais il fallait boire une vodka
avant
c'était trop tard
il n'y a pas que des stars qui ont
cultivé l'art de se faire du bien ces
montagnes il fut un temps et est le
repaire de staline ils possédaient 18
datcha des résidences d'été qu'il
faisait peindre en vert pour mieux les
camoufler nous avons demandé à nina de
nous y conduire elle connaît l'histoire
de sa ville sur le bout des doigts avec
ces périodes fastes et les plus sombres
[Musique]
tout le monde savait qu'il avait une
maison ici mais personne ne pouvait
jamais l'avoir au total dans tout le
caucase sur la côte de la mer noire
staline en avait 10 et leur emplacement
été choisies de façon à ce qu'on ne les
voyait pas sauf si on les survoler en
avion
staline qui a séjourné seulement à deux
reprises mais cela suffit pour que le
lieu soit aujourd'hui transformée en
musée
des visites sont organisées durant
lesquelles le petit père des peuples en
prend pour son grade
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
staline n'a jamais été quelqu'un de très
grande et très gaillard il n'aimait pas
posée et chacune de ces photos étaient
reproduites de nombreuses fois et
souvent même améliorée souvent aussi ses
portraits étaient brodés sur des tapis
l'agente ya un exemple dans ma main
c'est un portrait brodé avec du fil de
soi mais le problème c'est que staline
sur des portraits comme celui ci
ressemble à qui vous voulez mais pas à
lui-même en réalité il était petit il
mesurait un mètre soixante quatre
seulement
ils avaient des doigts très court ses
cheveux étaient roue et non pas noire
comme sur toutes les images officielles
et comme on nous l'a enseigné tout ça ce
sont des signes de problèmes physiques
et pour couronner le tout son père était
un alcoolique notoire
des propos qui dérange critiquer celui
qui dirigea l'urss pendant 30 ans les
pas au goût de tout le monde
excusez moi j'aimerais bien vous poser
une question moi je me souviens peu de
l'époque de staline je me souviens du
jour de sa mort tout le monde pleurait
s'il était si mauvais comme vous le
dites alors pourquoi le peuple at-il
tant pleuré sa mort aujourd'hui le pays
est complètement détruit toutes ces
richesses volées nous n'avons plus de
fabrique plus d' usine en a plus de
travail avant on n'avait pas de chômeurs
et maintenant ils sont partout vous
comprenez alors dire les choses que vous
dites sur staline ce n'est pas juste il
a emprisonné tout le monde mon père a
été arrêté alors je sais de quoi je
parle
qu'est ce que vous dites qu'est ce que
vous racontez il n'y a pas une famille
qui n'en ai pas souffert il a éliminé 30
millions de personnes et vous les avez
compté ce saint louis et je les lui mon
père a été arrêté mon oncle a fait dix
ans de prison pour rien
je suis choqué cet homme vient de dire
que staline n'a rien fait de mal moi
quand mon père est revenu de prison il a
passé le pas de la porte et a perçu le
portrait de staline il a saisi un cane
en faire et dit ce [__] est le seul
coupable il a pris cadenas et l'a jeté
sur le portrait
[Musique]
malgré les polémiques le lieu est devenu
un hôtel pour moins de 50 euros les
amateurs de frissons historiques peuvent
dormir dans ses appartements et même
déguster des plats préférés de staline
boeuf à la crème accompagné d'une
bouillie de sarrasin
[Musique]
aujourd'hui sotchi s'enivre de cocktail
de musiques occidentales et de gogo
danseuse nous entrons avec bastien dans
la boîte la plus branchée de la ville
contrôle anti armes 50 euros l'entrée la
plateforme est le rendez vous de tout ce
que le pays compte de nouveaux riches
starlette artistes et sportifs de renom
la plupart débarque tout droit de moscou
et saint-pétersbourg en avion privé et
puis il ya les autres ceux qui n'ont pas
les moyens mais veulent connaître quand
même
en musique c'est tout le monde sait les
gros salaires le salaire de l'hérault
salaire gelé car il avait derrière
[Musique]
l'aï déjà les salaires
ce qui fait la réputation de l'endroit
ce sont les danseuses elles viennent de
moscou et danser ici c'est pour elle le
signe de la réussite
alors voici natia l'ena à l'iss et à
nathalie et moi je m'appelle aliona
[Musique]
on est 10 mai vous pourrez pas nous voir
tout en même temps car il ya toujours au
moins une fille sur scène
ici on nous demande de danser de manière
assez sportive et érotique à la fois je
sais pas vraiment comment vous expliquer
en fait il faut que les hommes tous les
hommes nous regardent extasié et que les
jeunes femmes elle n'est qu'une envie
nous copier
je peux vous garantir que c'est dur de
ne pas nous regarder
c'est grâce à nous que ce club est le
meilleur de la ville ici on met la barre
très haut comme dans les clubs de moscou
le niveau est très bon ne faites pas
attention aux vestiaires on est en plein
travaux
[Musique]
mais plus sérieusement ici nous avons
les meilleurs clients toutes les stars
l'élite de la société russe qui
débarquent chaque semaine
les décibels de la plateforme
résonneront jusqu'à l'aube à l'heure où
les premiers baigneurs investissent les
plages
après un réveil difficile bastien
voulait nous emmener prendre un bol
d'air frais sur les hauteurs de la ville
le dimanche les habitants de sotchi un
petit venir pour admirer la vue et ses
bas des abords de ce vieux télésiège
attention les filles ça va arriver
[Musique]
allez c'est parti
là vous voyez le plus vieux télésiège de
la station le tout premier qui a vu le
jour ici et c'est un morceau d'histoire
tout le monde emprunte et chez tout le
monde le connaît à sotchi il avait du
charme il va disparaître ça me fait de
la peine mais qu'est ce que je préfère
[Musique]
pouvoir romantique vous savez les gens
se prennent dans les bras et
s'embrassent et les hommes se mettent à
dire des jolies choses dans les oreilles
des femmes
[Musique]
cette petite station de ski vit ses
dernières heures avant un grand
chambardement car d'ici quatre ans une
cité olympique va sortir de terre sotchi
a été choisie pour accueillir les
prochains jo d'hiver et tout est à faire
difficile d'imaginer des pistes
enneigées à seulement 30 minutes de la
mer je pense aux rochers lier les armes
on voit pas bien mais là c'est un super
spot pour sauter avec la neige derrière
là juste là on prend un peu d'élan
[Musique]
ce dimanche là pas de neige sur les
pistes mais beaucoup de monde sur les
sentiers ils sont venus profiter d'une
dernière escapade sur les sommets avant
qu'il ne devienne un immense chantier
les travaux sont énormes c'est pas beau
c'est sûr mais c'est pour la bonne cause
il faut construire le monde entier va
débarquer ici pour voir et pour
participer aux jeux olympiques et la
russie n'a pas le droit de se
ridiculiser il faut montrer qu'on est au
même niveau que l'europe et qu'en quatre
ans on est capable de construire toutes
ces nouveautés et d'améliorer la vie des
gens ici oui je pense pareil que toi et
votre président medvedev il sort s est
prêt
[Musique]
la mer la montagne et pour finir des
eaux souterraines miraculeuse le trésor
de sotchi est au bout de cette route
c'est là que l'histoire de la ville a
commencé
[Musique]
chaque fin de semaine touristes et
habitants débarquent par centaines dans
cet imposant bâtiment tout en marbre
construit sous staline
c'est lui qui avait décidé de construire
ces termes
les eaux de la matte cesta littéralement
les eaux de feu pourrait tout soigner et
nombreux sont ceux qui veulent y croire
nina y vient régulièrement le dimanche
après midi
le lieu a été construit comme un vrai
palais le style est très classique c'est
ce qu'on appelle l' architecture
stalinienne parce que tout le bâtiment a
été construit sous ses ordres
juste à côté il avait sa datcha et il
venait ici pour recevoir des soins c'est
pour ça que le bâtiment est si beau et
bien sûr c'est très agréable de venir
ici et de se sentir comme une vraie
petite princesse
[Musique]
un palais pour le peuple est un quartier
vip pour les hauts dignitaires du régime
car ils avaient leurs habitudes ici
staline puis brejnev compter parmi les
clients les plus célèbres ils venaient
dans cette annexe pour recevoir des
soins en toute discrétion
le lieu était restauré récemment dans
l'esprit des années 40 car les riches
hommes d'affaires qui viennent
aujourd'hui aime retrouver l'ambiance
des glorieuses années soviétiques
[Musique]
lorsque brejnev est arrivé ici pour la
première fois ses gardes du corps
étaient obligés de le porter ce n'est
pas une légende des témoins l'ont vu il
le tenait par dessous les brins pour
l'amener ici pour monter les quelques
petites marches mais une fois qu'il
avait pris son bain plus besoin d aide
il esquisse et même quelques petits pas
de danse c'est pour ça qu'il est resté
si longtemps au pouvoir c'est ça la
magie des eaux de maths c'est ça
depuis plus d'un siècle on s'y presse
pour soigner rhumatismes brûlures
maladies respiratoires et problèmes de
peau les vertus thérapeutiques de ses
eaux sulfureuses était connu dans toute
l'union soviétique
[Musique]
le jour s'achève sur les hauteurs de la
ville nous retrouvons sacha dans le
quartier populaire où ils habitent et
qu'il ne quitterait pour rien au monde
il y vit depuis 20 ans il a pu s'acheter
un trois pièces avec vue sur mer parce
qu'il était le plombier de l'immeuble
une sorte d' avantages en nature
accordés par le régime soviétique
le 6ème là haut c'est chez moi c'est un
très bon quartier ici je ne voulais pas
vivre dans le change il ya trop de
voitures là bas chez nous c'est beaucoup
mieux même le président à sa deuxième
maison là haut sur la colline c'est pas
pour rien
faites vous belle les filles allez venez
du pain s'il te plaît il ne reste que du
pain blanc
bien sûr un petit village et si
moi je connais tous les habitants de
l'entrée numéro une numéro deux et même
la numéro 3 et tout le monde se connaît
[Musique]
le dimanche soir sacha et olga dresse la
table dans la cour pour un barbecue en
famille ouvert aux amis de passage
le cabinet
je prépare des chachlyk regarder ses
morceaux de viande comme ils sont beaux
on a un sentier
un peu de vinaigre du vin maison et
quelques feuilles de l'orgie
a le chic c'est un truc de mecs
[Musique]
préféré rester à ce week end oui on a
l'impression d'être à la campagne ici
c'est notre petit datcha oui regardez il
ya tout ce qu'il faut ici l'air les
arbres
il y a toujours de la musique les
chansons populaires qui parle du temps
passé et même de la guerre un air de
nostalgie qui plonge des convives dans
une douce mélancolie rien de triste
plutôt de la sérénité
on s'est toujours dit qu'on avait de la
chance de vivre ici la mer nord nous
apporte beaucoup d'énergie positive et
je le ressens à chaque fois que je
quitte la vie depuis 35 ans la première
chose que je fais en revenant coter
d'aller la voir sinon elle me manque
terriblement
rien qu'en sentant la brise on se sent
beaucoup mieux
[Musique]
si vieux
et vous croirez nous c'est contagieux
[Musique]